this morning we have a special edition
of our Saturday session with the story
of one of the country's unique music
venues for decades New York's Forest
Hills Stadium was home to the US Open
tennis tournament in the 1960s the venue
also hosted some iconic music concerts
featuring legendary artists like the
Beatles and Frank Sinatra but when the
tennis tournament moved to a new
location the music faded away - and the
stadium fell into disrepair that is
until a promoter and a popular band took
a leap of faith and revived a venue that
is like no other in the nation we're 14
minutes from Manhattan but you sometimes
talk to people and they're like Forest
Hills where as far as tells you might as
well be on Mars but Forest Hills stadium
is actually nestled in a residential
neighborhood in Queens and is once again
becoming a music magazine thanks to live
event production company Madison house
presents and its co-president Mike Luba
after the who played here you witnessed
a moment between Roger Daltrey and Pete
Townsend what happened one of the
beauties about being in an open-air
space when it's nice out it just is
intangible how powerful and Roger walked
over to PETA he said you know hey mate
it's night it's like tonight why we
still do this
built in 1923 Forest Hills Stadium was
once the center of sports and culture in
New York a cathedral of tennis it was
the original home of the US Open where
Althea Gibson broke the color barrier
[Applause]
presents the trophies to two big winners
Althea Gibson and now Anderson Arthur
Ashe became the first and only
african-american man to win a US Open
and Billie Jean King demanded equal pay
it was also home to one of a kind
concert experiences everything from the
Beatles landing a helicopter on the
grass court the who Jimi Hendrix walking
off tour with the Monkees Bob Dylan
playing his gig after going electric at
Newport for the first time it felt quiet
for nearly 20 years until 2013 when Luba
brought Mumford and Sons in for a show
[Music]
[Applause]
it was just concrete and we did it full
general mission and we did the math in
the capacity for 17,000 people and then
about halfway through at about 8:30 it
was people started back and down the
stairways where they if you went to the
bathroom you couldn't get back to your
girlfriend or husband or wife the first
like 300 emails we got were that was
awful the porta-potties are gross I
couldn't get back to my mom it stunk
send me back my money I'm never coming
again
well we refunded four hundred thousand
dollars that night and I think that
signal to the neighborhood that we
weren't messing around
I think that first show we had to like
someone had to do it someone had to get
that show up on on the books and there
are no regrets according to a band
member Ben Lovett Mumford and Sons has
now played Forest Hills three times we'd
love to keep coming back it kind of has
the same gravity of the Hollywood Bowl
or red foxes is that important I think
the venues of America support from bands
like Mumford & Sons was just part of
starting a new chapter in the stadium's
legacy the other part buy-in from the
community
that's why Forest Hills has been
tailored to fit its environment and then
right here we've kind of explain what's
happening cuz people were freaking out
they felt like they're having problems
with their ears but the walls truly were
specifically designed to minimize the
sound that reaches our neighbors across
the street and for the fans inside what
are some of the things that you've seen
over the 6 years that you've been here I
think we've seen the fan experience get
exponentially better when we put in the
real bathrooms and cut the lines in half
which enabled us to build more bars and
more food we've really dialed the sound
so that it sounds concert level
full-blown that's great as anywhere
without it actually bothering anyone
the stadium's hidden features are also a
draw like the last remaining phone booth
from the 1968 US Open I'm laughing
because there's really a phone in here
and we have a picture of Arthur Ashe who
we think is calling his mother after he
won the US Open you do this it is not a
porta potti is definitely not a porta
potti each VIP section is a speakeasy
suite designed by Carey Silvestri of OTR
Collective this is all truly about the
experience and bringing you back to the
time and the era where this was so
important when we start designing from
the 1920s to the late 60s and that's how
each suite has its own little theme for
Mike Luba moving forward for Forest
Hills means honoring the past all of it
this was the ancestral birthplace of the
Davis Cup so I think that'll be a great
day for everyone when there's
world-class professional tennis
on on center court here in a concert
maybe the next time the concert maybe
after this after the match